[Music]
[Music]
when it's cold outside there's nothing
like a warm bath to tick off the chill
and these monkeys have found a great one
[Music]
the G Goku Donny Valley in Japan is
buried in snow for almost 1/3 of the
year the area is more commonly known as
hell's Valley named for its high
altitude jagged cliffs and bubbling hot
springs that fill the air with steam the
local Japanese macaques or snow monkeys
have found an interesting way to adapt
to these cold conditions
in the early 1960s these clever and
curious creatures moved down from the
higher forests and tested the water of
the natural Hot Springs they have been
using them as a spot to warm up in the
winter months ever since
these snow monkey is like company their
average group is typically 41 monkeys
but can range from 10 to 161 they're not
picky eaters either they'll eat just
about everything from seeds plants and
fruits or hand out from a mischievous
tourist even in the high mountains of
Japan these clever critters have found a
great way to relax spa day anyone
[Music]
commandest be about how stinky make the
school money untold history mother have
been system under I see cards Bahamas be
emergency Koenig oblivion is his
logistic average make pita my name is
Andrea on the sweeper Falcons here and
PA shrimp are here in the Paradise
talkback which was talking packet a
Vincenti whole cities around boffins and
Yahoo knock tidal power I and had the
power I learned about the hotels were
chef in the a diva conveniently about
Martin in the gear petitioned approver i
beaten beyond strongest yet stamp even
button as a service McCallum digital
left via Yahoo
national television once in Simba saw
designers constant mile we know sound
and Alma sister would fit automatic on
tiny say find something out Sitaram
foreign cisterna chyli nice solution but
at an ending out i insane cannot assign
an output and played a factor hot
dhanyavad eco endeavor home Deloitte MBA
pardon me Nastasia set aside man exists
as Watson stratified intangible East
Indies abolished in this equation when
she oneself the opportunity cannot see
say the Peter Principle in here those s
in Sakhalin years was thinking chicken
and fish pasta
[Music]
nothing says Britain more than nope nope
keep going
ah yes there it is a nice cup of tea we
know we have China to thank for
introducing tea to the Western world but
how did it make its way to England and
become the cultural obsession is today
well that's all thanks to one Portuguese
woman the year 1662
the person Catherine of Braganza she
just won the hand of England's King
Charles the second with the help of a
very large dowry including money
treasures and spices this worthwhile
trade made her the Queen of England
Scotland and Ireland when she arrived to
her new homeland she brought with her
packets of loose leaf tea in crates
label transport Dervis aromatic us it's
a theory that this was later Berube ated
to te a T now T could all be found in
England but was only really used for
medicinal purposes Catherine continued
drinking tea to her heart's content and
as the new royal everything about her
including her beverage habits was copied
by other ladies desperate to be just
like their Idol another thing Catherine
brought to the table from Portugal was
the idea of tea drinking experience she
popularized the use of porcelain tea
cups and mugs but the end of the 17th
century much of British aristocracy were
enjoying the hot beverage and soon
enough so was everyone else today while
tea can be found pretty much everywhere
it remains a special daily pastime for
Brit
hmm so carry on and drink tea people of
England in Saskatoon Saskatchewan you'll
find for senior citizens making socks
lots and lots of socks talks by Bob have
knitted eleven thousand six hundred and
sixty-two as of today that's pairs of
socks which means socks by Bob has
knitted twenty-three thousand three
hundred twenty four individual socks
eight point eight miles of socks and
they're all for charity the main
responsible for all these socks is none
other than bob rutherford enter bob's
knitting machines these super powered
knitting machines go at ninety turns per
second that's pretty fast but what makes
these machines special are that they're
self-made I'm an experimenter I just
build things and it took a long time to
figure out how to do it but when you're
retired and nothing to do it's just sort
of green socks by Bob began in 2010
after the passing of Bob's wife Edith I
was a caregiver to my wife before she
died and my son came home and said dad
you need something to do I said well I
made these socks on this first knitting
machine and that sparked an idea making
socks for those in need but Bob doesn't
work alone he has plenty of help George
cuts the tube length Glen and Barney has
the tube socks Bob
each week bobbin is team that hundreds
of socks that they then deliver to
countless homeless shelters all
throughout Canada when fox are delivered
in Alberta Saskatchewan BC Red Deer
Calgary some of glowny to the northern
part of the province in sharp they go to
where they're needed people gotta keep
involved you just can't give up because
of bereavement or whatever the case may
be
I think the bending socks for needy
people is important people have to reach
out and touch each other I think that
they go older and this has helped me do
that and I think that's the key to life
you don't give up and find the purpose
find something that needs to be done and
do it
[Music]
over 2 billion cups of coffee are
consumed every day and it takes a lot of
people to make just one cup one man went
on a quest to figure out what it's like
to thank each and every one of them AJ
Jacobs is a writer who lives in New York
City hi I'm AJ and he's the first to
admit he can be a bit of a grouch my
default state is grumpiness I am very
good and noticing all the things that go
wrong so to make a change he started
giving thanks during dinner I would say
thank you to everyone who helped make my
meal until one night my ten-year-old son
was like you know dad those people can't
hear you if you really cared you would
go and thank these people in person and
that's when the light bulb went off he
decided to hone in on something he knew
he took for granted every day my morning
cup of coffee over the next 12 months
AJ set out to thank every single person
who had even the smallest role in his
morning cup of joe first it was his
local barista the roaster and the coffee
shop sorcerer whenever I thanked one
person they would say well I couldn't do
my job without this person so one person
led to another led to another led to
another you ventured outside the city
and eventually the country I thank the
folks who provide electricity to the
coffee shop the engineers who provide
the water the people who make the steel
the farmer and the importer the truck
driver
the person who paved the road even the
woman who painted the yellow lines in
the road so that my coffee beans could
safely arrive at my coffee shop I
remember I called the woman who does
pest control for the warehouse and I
said I know this sounds strange but I
want to thank you for keeping the
insects out of my coffee and she said
well that don't sound strange but thank
you you know I don't get a lot of
appreciation in my job
all in AJ ended up banking over 1,000
different people and while most were
pleasantly surprised by his gratitude
it's AJ who benefited the most the
experience has made me grateful for the
hundreds of things that go right every
day as opposed to the three or four that
go wrong I tell my friends that they
should try these gratitude trails
themselves they could just be small
gestures looking someone in the eye the
cashier at the drugstore and could be
sending a quick note to the designer of
a logo you love I will tell you that it
will make your life better
it's changed the way I lived my life in
[Music]
[Music]
the cold white north of Minnesota
there's a place that will get you warm
after a long day on the ice you can do
some fishing or have a tasty beverage
and it's something of a dream for Josie
I've always wanted to own a neighborhood
bar and we finally do mine's just
sitting on a frozen lake ice fishing is
a way of life around here for people it
gets so cold below zero temps quite
often which allows us to drive and put
houses out and drill holes in the lake
and fish when it gets cold enough in the
early winter
Josie's husband goes out and tests the
ice to make sure it's thick enough
if it is they can put the bar together
and then the ice hole can open the ice
here is so thick that this bar sits on
top of it to come to our bar on the lake
you just drive your car out on the ice
and park we don't have a parking lot you
just park wherever you want walk in and
have a beer
people like to fish and drink beer and
from our bar here you can do that all at
the same time the local favorite drink
here is called the minnow shot people
will actually take a live middle which
is fishing bait and put it into their
shot and drink it as delicious is that
seafood beverage sounds people come just
because the fact that the bar exists is
pretty amazing people's reactions to
this bar are from crazy to they don't
understand it that's the coolest thing
ever
they come from all over the world to see
it it's very seasonal we're only open 20
days if you're ever near lake light a
drive out on the ice Park come into the
bar and grab a bowl